And everybody, this is Dr. Conner's and this section of our membership site is going to be on our protocol binder.
Now, your protocol binder cover might not look exactly like this. That's the only one I had to use on this slide.
However, your protocol binder is really your playbook. It is really what we want you to follow when you look at your diet.
You'll see pages like this. If you haven't really investigated your protocol binder,
you're missing out at a big piece of what we're trying to do for you.
So when we test you, we're putting what those findings are in this binder. So look at this binder.
I know many of you have asked questions like, oh, I did looked at this study and they said this is good for my cancer.
Well, by all means, you could add that too. But you are utilizing our services to specifically test you for what we think is right.
Not just to make, you know, educated guesses based upon data that's out there.
We're doing testing to come up with this. Now you can certainly change this and tweak this however you want to do it.
But this is how we lay it out for you. So make sure you look at your protocol binder.
In that protocol binder, it also has some information on the right machine and how to maybe troubleshoot if you're having any issues with it.
So make sure you look at that. There's tabs in that binder that go to all sorts of data, including spiritual things like your daily practice of affirmations of who you are in Christ.
Look at those things too. So utilize the binder. I can't tell you how many times we talk to somebody and they haven't even looked at that yet.
So make sure you look at that. Now what issue that we've had with the binder is some of you started with us a month ago.
And you have all of our updates on the binder of everything that we're doing now and everything that we're recommending now. But some of you started with us four years ago.
And so your binder is a little bit scared compared to what we're giving people today. So it was always a struggle like how do we update everybody?
Well, that's what the Zoom calls are for in such. But we want to update you with the latest information and that's the beauty of this membership site.
So on this section of the membership site, we're going to have all the updates of the binder.
So if you're missing something in your binder, this is where you'll find all the latest information.
So all the latest information that we're using for constipation or whatever issue, the latest information and how to do coffee enemas and such.
So look at this because we're updating it fairly regularly with new information because we're learning to.
So hopefully this section of the membership site will be a blessing to you. Thanks.